Okay, we also had questions about various web frameworks.
What exactly is a web framework, what makes something a web framework,
and what are some of the other popular web frameworks for Python
and popular web frameworks in general?
Sure. A web framework is basically the piece of your program that is speaking HTTP,
parsing URLs into a path, into a query,
and passing that into some handier functions that you define.
A web framework can do more or less things.
The type of web framework we're using in Google App Engine
actually, its lineage kind of dates back to a web framework we built at Reddit.
It's about the level of detail that I like to work at,
which is I don't think we should be implementing HTTP, but it's nice to be aware
what the headers are, of what the query parameters are,
and having direct control over the URLs.
Some frameworks--a very popular one on Python is called Django. It does a little bit more.
It'll add on sessions and user handling and form control and all sorts of stuff like that.
It's not very good for this class because I'm trying to teach you how that stuff works.
Now, with an understanding of how those things work that I think you can get out of this class,
knowing you'll have better understanding of the tradeoffs those frameworks make,
and what they're hiding from you and what they're exposing to you,
Some of which is convenient,
some of which can be tedious when you're trying to do something custom.
Outside of Python, really popular frameworks--
Ruby on Rails is probably one of the most popular ones.
Ruby on Rails and Django are actually fairly similar
in that they do a lot of stuff for you.
They hide a lot of the HTTP and a lot of the URL handling and parsing and all that stuff.
I don't like to work at quite that high a level, because I feel like
when you writing web applications it should to be so simple.
Tou should be close to it, because then you can do some neat stuff
when you're setting your own headers
and fiddling with your own cookies and hashing your own things.
There are lots of frameworks out there.
I think the Google App Engine is really kind of a nice layer for teaching.
It's actually the layer that I work in or that we used at Reddit
and Hipmunk in terms of the design of that framework.